j'accueille marc lavoine
comme sa marque sorbonne oui c'est moi
j'aime la saga je leur ai dit qu'ils
invitent je me barre non
l'art est un peu quand même deux minutes
je ne veux vraiment pas le voir c'est un
marc oui ça va bien alors vous avez été
élevé dans une culture politique
comparable celle de stomy bugzy culte de
malcolm x révolution des oeillets au
portugal cohn bendit votre père vous
disais toujours c'est formidable que
nous même dit qu'il est monté sur le
lion de belfort à denfert rochereau à la
retrouver métier c'était dans une
imprimerie avis où vous étiez en bleu de
travail alors je sais si vous connaissez
la banlieue il est un enfant du
communisme
chaque année votre père tenait un stand
à la fête de l'huma vous vendiez le le
muguet le 1er mai et même si depuis vous
avez épousé la dernière descendante des
rois de pologne dans est toujours en
contact comme avec la réalité quoi c'est
vrai j'avais réunion c'est plus que les
affiches pour le programme commun que
j'étais un enfant aussi j'avais 14 ans
j'avais le trac est relatif savent
qu'ils aient pif gadget avec maurice
biraud j'avais la carte des jeunes
communistes ce qui me reste c'est si le
désir d'aimer les gens j'entends ce
discours aussi beaucoup dans des propos
d'homme sage n'est pas seulement
d'hommes politiques où je crois que ce
qui est important c'est d'aimer les gens
et d'essayer de développer autour de soi
une énergie comme ça de vivre ensemble
je crois que le prime de demain ce sera
à vivre ensemble il faut s'y attaquer
fraterniser magique royal mais si les
allemands ont été capables de prêter
remisé avec des français en 1914 sur les
tranchées pas pourquoi n'arriverait pas
à fraterniser que gens des banlieues
aujourd'hui non mais surtout qu'on est
on a affaire à des français
on est des français donc j'estime que
ils ont que les français issus des
migrations qui sont des frères et des
soeurs et que et on a un beau travail à
faire ensemble dans un joli pays il faut
le réussir
ça ne paraît pas impossible comment ça
va parce à bien et toi c'est vrai que ça
très bien alors c'est quoi cette
histoire d'un incendie d'appartement la
non mais c'était avant l'événement aura
lieu comme annoncé c'est quoi cette
histoire a brûlé symbole eh ouais
pourquoi votre création n'est peut-être
pas envie d'avoir un contrôle
non mais c'est fou comme ça peut faire
pour les possédés par les choses qu'on
possède une fois son dea plus c'est un
conte ton appart brûle on était attaché
à plein de trucs le mot il tu restes tu
es enfant et reste ta femme et reste ton
énergie et toute ton expérience tu l'as
en toi bon c'est un peu angoissant quand
tu trouves quand tu retournes dans
l'appartement que tu vois la chance de
ta fille est carbonisé et c'est donc
c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup de chance
quand on n'a pas en faire un plat parce
que quand j'ai quand j'ai vu les
familles entières ouais boulevard
vincent auriol et sans drame irréparable
l'a vraiment moi c'est la gnognotte
mais c'était dû à quoi cette histoire
d'un soir est jeune on écoute je
rentrais de voyage on les voit là où ma
femme était au fait la pub au foy's
enfin fait quand la crème
ma fille était à la maison avec sa
nounou ça s'est mis à brûler allez y ça
ils incendient non mais le problème des
glandes surrénales aussi fait brême et
twente suis tombé un peu malade à
sassari s'est allégée glandes surrénales
assez la cortisone totalement encore la
surrénale quand elle s'arrête
tu marches plus lentement que les gens
quand 92 ans dans la rue est un peu
fatigué c'est une incidence sur
l'érection discute à long terme tu veux
dire ou alors aussi le moment la seule
maman surmonter creux et donc ouais je
suis pas je voudrais pas rentrer et non
plus dans le détail c'est dû à quoi ça
les glandes surrénales les problèmes les
glandes surrénales c'est dû à quoi
le rapport aux reins toujours parce que
de bosser valeur étalon en chine tuant
et thématiques
oui ces souvenirs on va mettre un 10/10
groupe a bâché voile et de la musique
et puis accident de ski aussi non moi je
le cite une moquette
c'est à dire inspiré d'un côté j'étais
nos aéroports à en asie je partais que
mes enfants je me suis pété la gueule
dans la moquette devant tout le monde à
l'aéroport et ma jambe s'est brisée
c'est un peu contre 7 chez reed
j'étais là-bas c'était sympa mais lyon
heureusement qu'est la musique quand
même non
nous
les yeux
elle
qui tu es
comment
partout des enjeux plus rien
laon aisne qui chantent
les ventes du jeu
m
l'amour qui tire
chaud
je
seibert
vente
5 je sent mauvais
heureusement je sais
layton
sur le son
même si
je
pour tous le même schéma
son prix
marzouki
ouais
un bel album s'appelle l'heure d'été le
deuxième single s'appelle toi mon amour
walou
merci
oui
j'ai soumis
fois mon amour ma ferme aux annexes de
rbc son mandat
alors on va voir à quoi ressemble
devions garder votre caméra un caracal
rouge
vous connaissez serge khalfon bonjour si
un jour ça va oui et vous dites magnéto
serge khalfon magnéto serge khalfon